- We had a potential brand integration with Tom Cruise, like we were gonna go to like-
- Tom Cruise is here right now. Yeah, I just, from what I hear, he's one of the nicest most professional people,
- I mean, I just can't say enough about how much of a special honor this is.
- He's, he's right there!
- He's right there, he's outside!
- Tuck it, tuck it, tuck it, tuck it!
- I'm just trying to be natural, I don't wanna be awkward.
- Just be yourselves.
- Hey!
- How're you doing?
- Good, how are you? I'm Jake.
- Pleasure to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nico! Hey, Nick.
- Hey, good to meet you.
- Clinton! I've heard a lot about you.
- How's tether going, is it good?
- Got the financing yet?
- We've been struggling with that a little bit.
- Well, you know it takes time but you know, I'm here to help I'm a helper. Yeah, that's what I do
- Help me help you!
- (laughing)
- Yeah, I mean-
- we'd love for you to help us any way you can with that.
- Well, tell me about Dobby, is Dobby causing you trouble still?
- Every day.
- How do you know about Dobby?
- I follow everything,
- I mean, I might say got my finger on the pulse, you know, I mean the zeitgeist!
- (laughing) Woo!
- You follow us?
- I follow you yeah if I know everything about you.
- Wait, are you subscribed to the channel?
- Right, I rung the bell.
- Yeah?
- To get a little subscription plus action,
- Yeah!
- and I'm having the time of my life.
It's such an honor. It's an honor and a privilege. They don't forget that that's so cool
Did you see the Tom Cruise impersonation like Olympics that we did? Yes. Yes, and I heard you won. Usually you tucked your shirt
Mm-hmm. Well, you know, what? Can you untuck it while I'm here cuz it's making me a little uncomfortable
Sure. Yeah. Yes just right now thank you. It was just a fun thing
I know I know but his past is in the past and I live in the moment. Yeah. Yes. Yeah
Yeah, totally be too good. Yeah, let's let's let's uh, show me around watch it. Yeah, show me how it rail the magic. Yeah
yeah, I
Love water. Yes, maybe a pastrami sandwich. Thank you. So if you couldn't already tell this is not the real Tom Cruise
It's actually a deep fake and here's how he made it
Actually have some slight adrenaline going my heart is fluttering right now what we're trying here could get real crazy done
Two words you want a Sam Neko deep fix
President Trump is a total and complete
Find them show me a leadership capability
Deep fake is basically training a computer based on pattern and the image recognition
to understand the structure of a human face in one of the byproducts of this is that you can accurately
Replicate someone else's face onto another person's face. Now this gave me an idea
I want to put Tom Cruise George Tom Cruise. I would put his face on a celebrity impersonator
Back to normal they go and someone that can act like Tom Cruise
So when that looks like Tom Cruise someone that sounds like Tom Cruise
Would it be indistinguishable from the real thing
Does this mean that you can put any movie star you want into your videos if these defects end up working its gonna have some?
pretty big implications
In the world of not only film and television but also news and media and if it doesn't look good then we got some solid
Nightmare fuel coming up. So let's go see what happens
Yeah, do you know any celebrity impersonators?
Yeah
I mean kind of funny
Literally just over this weekend. Justin Bieber tweeted that he wants to take Tom Cruise in a fight in the Octagon
I don't know why but this official Tom Cruise impersonator replied
It was exactly like Tom Cruise battle normally fight girls Justin Bieber
He looks just yeah, he's that guy from LA yes, I believe he is
I think we sent a guy a DM he would respond to us. Actually not Tom Cruise being our video
I'm gonna tweet you right now. All right, so I'm going to be using a program called the deep face labs
It's actually free and get on now
If you want to deep pics of your own they're going to need a pretty decent graphics card
And you need a lot of video RAM thanks to Puget setting us up with a solid workstation here
I can run these deep fakes on this computer in pretty high resolution without too much strain
You want to see what kind of specs a fugitive there's a link in the description below
Here is my source video of my face the more structure more
Variations I can give the program with my face the more the program can learn what happened today
One of the issues people have said is like hey, I baked this person
But they don't blink at all and that's because they don't have any frames for to learn where the eyes are closed me
Make sure you provide it with all these different poses all these different profiles and perspectives and now I'm going to be putting it on
Rent here
so once I'm ready to go once I have much in video clips
I need to extract the faces the program's going in and actually doing some facial recognition. Here are the eyes. Here's the nose
Here's the mouth just to isolate the face and a line once I've extracted the faces
I need to train the program into how the faces work the faces on the left are the ground truth
So speak they are my face from a picture the blurry thing next to it is a cork
I'm going to iteration by iteration by iteration
looking at the pictures and trying to learn and trying to match it and the closer it can get it's
Artificially generated image to the actual ground truth image the better
It's doing little by little it has become clearer and clearer
Then we have Ren his ground truth of his face in the synthesized version his face and on the far right we see the computer
Trying to recreate my face based on Ren's structure
So friends making a funny face at this mouth open the computer is trying to go
Okay, what would Nico's face look like with the mouth open?
And it's trying to put my face into that pose
Basically anytime Bryn's expressions don't match things that I've done the computer is having a hard time filling in the gaps
It needs a little more training as to what that looks like so I can go back and we could try to find more pictures
Of me in that pose. I could just take me pictures, you know, it should clean that up for the sake of this test
I'm not too worried about that
If I have any issues like this in the Tom Cruise test, I will go through and find pieces
I need to fix it to make sure that it's flawless. This guy's really talented
So these deep fakes are pretty sweet, right?
But I wanted to let you guys in on a little secret of something that I've been doing. That's even more convincing
It's called shallow fakes and shallow fakes are so simple and easy to use but it's almost like today's sponsor
Squarespace it looks just like them
It does five put this on I can go around and actually convince people in the studio that I'm Niko you here. Ready? Just wait
Niko hey, Nick you guys might have thought that that was Niko. It's Jake
Hey Christian, what's up me go. Would you mind if I told you a little some about today's sponsor Squarespace?
Sure Squarespace is an all-in-one platform. It's the best way to build a business or just a website online makes me go. You're welcome
What are you working on
Nico you look a little pale, you know
I'm still waiting for summer to come in beautiful thing about Squarespace is that you can do
Simultaneous posting where if you post something on Squarespace can also show up on your Twitter and Facebook beat, isn't that cool?
Yeah, I didn't actually know you can do that
I think Jake learned today that you can post audio like a podcast on to Squarespace
It'll just embed it and make it easy to access for all your fans. They have multiple contributors
You guys could contribute to order Digital calm
Hey, would you would you like to would you like to go on a one wheel ride later? I'm one wheel
It's kind of batteries. But you wanna make cheese or sausage later. I'm a little full but I'll be hungry eventually cool. Hey Dean
Hey how have your first few weeks been here at corridor? They've been great Nikko. Thanks
Thanks for asking. Dean Squarespace allows you to own all the content that you post on your website
Apparently there are some rumors out there or if you didn't own the content that you post on Squarespace that's untrue
Do I look like I'd lie about that. No, no Nikko. I don't think you would
There you have it Oh Jim's coming. Jen's gonna be here any minute
Don't go out there Nico be careful it is I Nico
It's just me
If you guys are interested in creating your own
Beautiful website go to Squarespace comm slash core or Cru and you get 10% off your first purchase of a URL or a website template
enjoy
Evan Ferrante aka not Tom Cruise is confirmed coming on was a down
Oh wait, you think you can run at as much of an angle as I can?
I was excited to have a celebrity impersonator in the studio. This works. It's gonna look pretty bizarre. It's gonna look like he's here
Hey
Vijay Niko. Yes, Kevin. Yeah Jake. What's up? Jake? Nice to meet you. Yeah
When did you realize this was the thing my friend? He does a John Claude Van Damme impression. Does he do the splits?
You didn't do the splits. Oh, he did that bit
he said you sound and look and have the
Mannerisms of the crews and he said let's like team up and meet women this way and I didn't even have glasses at the time
I didn't have a wig which I do today
I don't want to I don't like to break the illusion and it turned into a career. It's totally surreal
I've had like a little bit of a loss of identity through the years the guy Mike Who am I you'll ever met Tom Cruise
You had I didn't go to sleep that night
I went I was at the Chateau as one does you know like I knew someone at another table this attorney guy
He called me over. He said I heard Tom Cruise's in the building
I had been in personally for eight years at that time, but my heart was racing, you know, I was getting sweaty
He wasn't there like and I go back to my seat kind of resigned to the fact that I wasn't gonna meet him
I just suddenly feel like this energy to the side of me
He's right there, but you cannot you cannot talk to celebrities in the garden and you cannot talk to Tom Cruise
He kind of gets up and like, you know, which makes people and just like it says goodbye just like this is amazing
That's what I do and he leaves it's just me and my friend Jimmy in the that's it
It's 2:00 in the morning and suddenly he gets a call. He said to me Tom Cruise is waiting for you in the lobby
no, and I
Said shut the he was and I get up out of my chair
I sprint from the guard and I just sprint was this I go lobby. Yeah, he was there waiting for me
It's I swear time stopped. It was like a slow turn and we it's like a cataclysmic reaction. We just like mutual appreciation
Admiration we both said at the same time. It's an honor and a privilege to meet you and I
Could not it was the most surreal thing ever the most exciting moment of my life
Nothing else mattered except for us in that moment. We fell in love
I'd like to show you the technology that we face please a little intro to the video. I'm talking about the technology. Yeah
Oh my god. Thank you. And that's Tom on you
Yeah, very scary Computers learning the actual structure of Tom Cruise's manners into the expressions. It's learning it
Yeah, but we did a we did a Tom Cruise contest okay to do a few months back
I did end up winning give you some example. Oh, yeah, what is it you do. I'll just do a little montage
Let's see what it's like without any deep take right now. Let's see how close we get
This is it. This is it. It's gonna make sure that here's it, you know already start to hear it in my voice
I'm just gonna do a countdown 5, 4,
3, 2
You don't know what it's like to be out here for you
It is a pride falling up at dawn siege that I can never fully tell you
That's just help me help you! Help me help you!
My name is Nico Clemens Nico. Yeah, who's got a short-term memory? I shake a lot of hands you
Clean let's say I've been following your work and fan, you know, you work with such incredible, you know people around you and yeah
Yeah, really? I really sense your passion here run. Will you do me the honors? Here's the finger-point?
It's a privileged man. It's an honor and a privilege. Yeah
Dudes breathtaking I feel it too
You know, I feel like you know, he's very composed
But when I do it I just you know, I get I get caught up in it. I try to channel him
Do we need the deep fake? I'm sure we need to
Can you do better than this? I don't know
You're gonna break the AI and I wasn't joking before
I do have somewhat of a loss of identity through the years from doing it so much, you know, I mean
There's not a day that goes by that I don't get asked to do it. I love doing it
It gives me a lot of joy to do it. So look, I feel a little bit naked without the glasses
I will hide behind the deep fake, but I will also merge with it
I will I will become one. There comes a deep takes all it is mass. Yeah, you still need the craft
You still need the inflection. You still need the mannerisms if you couldn't act and then wear that mask
Yeah, that's when you reach the full character for sure. I'm really excited about it
So I've done 250 thousand iterations to baking four days two days
I have stillness the small problems to work out. But this is the version now and it's pretty crazy
So obviously the color hasn't been matched yet
It looks really good, but we're not quite there yet
I think we all have like little ideas on what is making it fall short of perfection
I mean the obvious things are the eyeball because face is almost too big on his face. I think that is true
It's like his head shape isn't perfectly matched Tom Cruise. I mean you guys have already seen the scene in the video
But yeah, we haven't made them yet. So we have a lot of shots of Tom Cruise and like some pretty complex motions
so, I don't know I
Just keep feeding it Tom Cruise. Source material. We I'm hungry. I'm gonna start a new model fresh here from scratch. Really
I'm gonna up to the resolution of everything to where I go off memory on my card
It's close I can get so you're gonna be quadrupling the resolution
I think that will hire the resolution will fix the long queue
But if you're going four times higher resolution, that means it's gonna take four times as much time. Yes
Well, you're just gonna have a train all weekend man. You bet. It's a slow cooker. I got a Tom Cruise pot roast going
All right. So these Tom Cruise cookies and baking in the oven all weekend, so they should be really nice
We've invited Evan back in and I get to show them basically this full transformation here. I'm really excited
You know, it's just this beautiful coming together moment. I hope he likes it
Okay, there's been a lot of a lot of build-up but I feel like this is gonna exceed my expectations
Oh, wow, that's Tom
Wow kind of a blank stare but I like it it is uncanny
Wow, this is very exciting to see it's it's a combination of terrifying but also incredibly entertaining the way the wrinkles
Yeah forming on your cheeks. Yeah, it's getting the proper like folds on the cheeks
And yeah, that's the knowledge but those are his teeth completely
That's all never said his tongue is in there. That's his tongue. Yep. Okay. He was once your tree in the face
It's not that hard to put it on new face
It's like I can we could film with you for another minute here and I could have it
Face Swap you by the end of the hour like I have been fighting your face near two faces. Yeah
I think that really sets this apart from any other depict out there honestly is
Your voice there's no deep fake for voice right now
So you're giving us a voice that is elevating anything visual where that we're doing. Yeah. This is my new crutch that I lean on
But I will also burden this is as far as I've come to you know becoming conjoined inside melted I
Would love to hear Tom's reaction if you just if you just looked over and was just like dude no
Means do you feel like if you just said it?
Thank you so much for lending us some talents and skills and abilities and any all of our entire Honor privilege
Hey guys Tom Cruise here back in the corridor digital studio
I just wanted to say they have a
Wonderful patreon, but they've got all these great people who support the videos that they make this one right here
This is Wendy Deptula. Hi
Thanks Wendy for supporting us on patreon and this guy right here Phillip Oxford or you are you Astro GG either way
It's an honor and pleasure to meet you
Hey, are you Alan L Monza? Hey
Agency, are you watching the lion's head YouTube channel, cuz they support us too
I will be I will be great and just remember war master, two three, six and Matt
He are also great patreon supporters. Let's hear you will Robertson, uh
Yeah, you lot of Canadian spy or any Adolf. They all support us, too
I think I'm all of them a little bit. I think I am too
Hey guy, are you a radio Guerrero Mitch Polanski or glitch cube?
I can't quite tell I am talking honor and pleasure to meet you. Thanks for being here. Hey guy. Hey, Tom, welcome back
Alright, are you James Bailey or Raymond debat? I'm Brian and toesik. Hey, Brian. Oh, yeah
Everyone on that list. So phenomenal can't say enough about it
They got me down here right finger on the pulse all that stuff hit the button
It's got the notification squad going consider supporting these guys patreon.com/scishow order quarter digital